il y à un peu plus d'un an
la famille alamo posé ses valises à
drummondville un mois plus tard ward se
découvre et pâtissière dans la
coopérative du regroupement qui les
soutient mohammad voulais trouver un
travail dans la construction pour se
passer de l'aide de l'état
raga dérouard était déjà en classe de
francisation alors que les parents
attendaient leur place où en sont-ils
[Musique]
hello
fadlallah savary bonjour il vient à
chaque fois qu'ils ont des questions par
rapport à l'école c'est l'endroit dans
lequel ils se sentent vraiment
conscience il se sent à l'aise effet
soir moi c'est clara aux toits et je
suis intervenants comme on ne tarit
scolaire interculturel ici en europe a
menti interculturel d'être mobile
je vous suis demandé de venir ici au
bureau pour vous donner des informations
de l'école pendant douze années 2003
anne il faut les accompagner
on ne peut pas le laisser ok ça fait un
an qu'elle est ils sont déjà là et qui
il communique
non il faut continuer à les accompagner
j'imaginais un club de francisation ça
va bien nettoie la cadic toi loi aussi
ça va bien des saveurs d'ailleurs
qu'elle joue va-t-elle à la rencontre
des louvre le vendredi qui peuvent venir
les créer
elle est plus à l'aise au début il était
très timide et là
elle est capable de fonctionner en
français on lui pose des questions elles
répondent rapidement
c'est un débrouillard et enseignants
classe d'accueil pour les migrants à la
regarde pour l'arrestation
je dois faire comme d'habitude qu'est ce
qu'on fait d'habitude le titre ba da
c'est votre canard il connaît français
vient de parler c'est de commencer c'est
beau c'est parler avec l'autre jamie
aller acheter comme ça par les français
le défi va être au niveau 2
réintégrer les classes qui sont de
niveau secondaire elle est capable de se
débrouiller en français mais de
reprendre l'histoire du québec que la
géographie
elle va avoir de l'anglais
le serait pas
un énorme progrès qui constant voie
créée aussi beaucoup de liens avec les
autres enfants la barrière de la langue
est de moins en moins représente pour
elle
je suis peut-être serveurs enseignante
francisation primaire à l'école frédéric
d'être où je travaille beaucoup en
collaboration avec les autres classes de
l'école ici
[Musique]
ça les oblige à crayons avec ses onze
élèves et tranquille aux malades est
venue exprimer sur l île se rejoignent
dans la cour d'école
[Musique]
des fois on se pose des questions parce
que elle a connu plus à cilic mois
il faut beaucoup beaucoup dit moi je
connais parce qu'anna dockers qui elle
banque l'enfant commence naturellement
créé des liens vinci triste sécurisé et
l'estimé de soi la confiance en soi
après c'est plus facile d'aller vers les
autres se sentir autonome dans ses longs
centres de visionnement vous n'avez pas
ce bon dîner waouh
qu'est ce que tu as mangé je mangeais
maïs oui on joue orange oui eux ont
carrément dit oui une clémentine
vraiment et que l'on manquait clémentine
je m'appelle jusqu'à nicotine je suis
enseignante à la francisation au centre
sainte-thérèse de drummondville et
aucune ressemblance entre l'arabe et le
français dont tous les mots doivent être
prononcés pour répéter et souvent eux
ils se traduisent le sont par exemple si
je vous dis nourriture ils vont prendre
dans le world elle prend tout les
syllabes du mot et les cris les signes
la rame pour hervé bien prononcé le mot
ça vaut discuter des éléments importants
de votre vie
on va écrire mon arrivée au canada et
j'aimerais que vous mettiez la date
à côté de cette phrase l'homme mois
chance je suis arrivé au canada 4
janvier 2016 c'est pour souligner nous a
dit qu
pour nos couleurs de t'envoyer où le
créole c'est le niveau d'éducation la
principale difficulté pour moi tant
qu'enseignante j'ai des élèves qui
arrivent dans ma classe analphabètes
dans leur langue maternelle
donc ni l'écriture ni l'élection n'était
acquise dans une langue de base comme ci
comme ça ça va conduire à la tête à
gauche à gauche à droite tout droit je
pense que la meilleure activité qu'on a
trouvée pour battre a dit que français
le adapter la voiture
oui c'est mort plus tard je pense que
tout le monde c'est barbant tôt
[Musique]
c'est pour voir et c'est beau c'est
ça revient thome a droit attention
attention attention ne sais pas c'est
l'ambition on laisse toujours pensé sais
pas si on fait rien pour nous accueillir
ça va pas marcher quelque chose que je
[Applaudissements]
regarde comment voulez vous qu'ils
apprennent vraiment prince et s'ils nous
sont au québec on lance alpin français
parce que je suis vue qui évolue d'un
francis faut donner le temps soit
créatif de trouver des activités ou si
toi m
paris par un saumon loin des copeaux
faut que soit la gauche hugo veuve de
fonds publics
moi je prenne mon réseau déjà je les
emmenais chez ma soeur jamais au café
rencontre les amis après maintenant mais
à nous disperser les voix révélées salut
et ça s'appelle comme un le canton non
moulin lamour
on avait une grande et a pas longtemps
après qu'elle soit arrivée
son père est mort frey après c'est pas
parler beaucoup seulement celles
exercées par les mre ward aimerait
enseigner aux enfants
mohammad lui a hâte de trouver un
travail n'importe lequel
leur priorité reste l'apprentissage du
français et leur souhait que web puisse
aller bientôt monture qui vous voir une
partie de sa famille
[Musique]